Hello my name is Monica Diaz and I'm going to have a
conversation with Adam Payne. ADAM PAYNE: Hi. MONICA DIAZ: Hello, for visible lives,
an Oral History Project at the New York Public Library it is
is February eighteenth two thousand fifteen and this is being recorded at the
the Inwood Public Library in New York. ADAM: It is. MONICA: Thank you so
so much
Adam. You know can we, can we start off by having you
Tell me a little bit about yourself.
Well, my name's Adam Payne, um
I was born a long, long time ago in a galaxy far, far away.
actually I was born in 1971 in Cambridge, Mass.
Jersey. And now I live in New York.
And about two and a half years ago I started to rock climb,
Which
? now.
And I'm good. I've won the ABS Nationals
twice in my division. So I've got two gold there.
and last year I won
Paraclimbing nationals in Atlanta. I won the bronze
bronze there. Which qualified me to go to Spain to the world's
in September, which i did.  I didn't win anything there
but that's OK. It was fun anyway. MONICA: You went to Spain. ADAM: I went to Spain.
Spain. Paid for it, but I went there. MONICA: That's great.
And what, what got you interested in
in...in
In rock climbing? Well, let's see, I
Well in two thousand and twelve I was an active cyclist.
And I was looking to uh, maybe do a cross-country bike trip
but I was thinking that with my disability, I really didn't want to set up a
tent every night. So I was going to get
"busy sack".  You know what a "busy sack" is? [Monica: No]
kind of a bag that you put over your sleeping bag to protect the thing that directly on the
ground and it gives it waterproof-ness. - Hmm, okay. - So it's like a
one man tent. And um
I thought where do you get the bivy sack?
EMS sprung to mind, so i went to EMS and they didnt have one.
but, they introduced me to one of their sales people
also disabled. Karima Bat MONICA:Karima? ADAM: Bat MONICA: Mm
who has one leg -- she's a wonderful person! And ah
she talked to me about
in March and it was now June and ah
we talked a bit about that program about what they were doing
found out that I would like to go to this program so she invited me
but I went - I started climbing with her in July and I've been hooked and
I climb 2 times a week -- 3 times if I'm training
for a competition. [Monica--"that's great, and"
So you've been doing this about...? Two and a half years - Two and a half years
Now
32 months.  [Monica, "How was it to start?"
Oh
Oh I had climbed before. [Monica, Okay.] - Not really well.
'cause when I was a kid
I was in New Jersey and I worked for a place called Campmar (?)
Worked in a place called Capmar.
And at the Capmar I was the director of a sporting good store
it was a great place to work I loved it because I was a ? at the time
And
um
They had a connection to a local climbing gym. This was in 1994
so there weren't very many local climbing gyms.  They were just getting started
this was a pretty bad climbing gym.
I loved it and, I started climbing there and I climbed for a
a couple months there.  And I improved very little
Didn't know what I was doing. A lot of it by
but that was about it. And then my climbing partner
stopped coming so I stopped climbing. And then I
and then i went on to another job and then i got diagnosed with [inaxia?]
And I really thought that my
climbing days were over. Didn't really care 'cause my climbing days didn't
had started.  I climbed twice after
I got
ataxia - I diagnosed, I'd had it all my life.
And ah, so then I
when I met Kareemah and started climbing at Brooklyn Boulders
I was very quickly able to start up at the level I'd left off at
five-six, now I'm at a five-nine, five-ten level.
Which is pretty good and
I've been sponsored by a major manufacturer
of climbing gear -- BackDrop Climbing - they make
shoes. They gave me a pair of shoes, which are great
It's nice being sponsored.
And, um (cough)
Excuse me.
[Monica: We can - feel free to take a break.] Nah, it's just
It may take a little bit more than an hour for me because - with all the water breaks
[Monica: Alright] Um, so that's about it. I've been sponsored by
Mad Rock. I met Kevin Jorgeson
(Coughing) at the end of January
He was one-half of the team that climbed the Dawn Wall in Yosemite.
.
You met him. I met him personally, I have a picture with him.
Well
it's kinda tough to tape something [Monica: Well, you know, if it's
okay with you maybe we can
Put that online.] I don't own
?
[Monica: You've met him at Brooklyn Boulders?] Yes.
[Monica: And what, what was it like?] It was nice.
Um
I take it he's one of your...
Oh wait, that's not going to show it. [Monica: I take it he's one of -
one of the climbers you, you really admire.] Yeah well,
I admire lots of people, but he's one of them.
.
[Monica: You'll have to share some of those photos with us.]
?
Here we are. [Moncia Awesome.] Yeah, awesome
She's really, uh, I've gotta picture of-- She's, uh
Addidas wanted to calm her.
Er, Adidas [Monica]: Adidas. [Adam:] Yeah. All day I dream about sports
sports-Adidas.
Are there other ac-activities
Activities or other sports that you are involved in?
[Coughs.] Excuse me.
Well, I cycle.
Uh, and, um...
I don't ride a regular bike. You may have seen me ride but I don't.
I ride the three-wheel recumbent bike. It's um real low to the ground.
I lean back. It's a, it's a nice bike. It doesn't go off road.
Well.
So, you've been, you've been planting for about two-and-a-half
years. You mention some of these awards. Um. Tell me a little bit more
more about what it, what that felt like, or... [Adam:] Well--
What you--
you... if you, were you aiming to
to...
To to to/ when did this competition-- [Adam, overlapping:] I wasn't, I wasn't aiming, when it--
two-and-a-half years ago, I wasn't aiming to be a competitive climber.
My competitive streak has definitely come out after I got disun--
--I found I was disabled. Um.
A lot of things have come out about me after I found I was disabled.
Um.
But now that I know that I'm competitive I enjoy winning.
I like winning. And winning the... gold medal
the ABS twice is a good thing. [Monica:] That's a...\ wonderful-- [Adam, overlapping:] It's a very good
[Monica:] --wonderful thing. [Adam, overlapping:] It's a very good thing at. Um.
Um.
Winning the Bronze in rock climbing, it's-- I swore to
do better. But my friend Carlos
. CONDIT Caffyn he could do could be
east is just amazing and he won the
gold and that there is no Again there and then kind of well
he's young talk much yesterday
and he won so over and I won the bronze.
So it didn't get right him as
he currently changer.
Now I just came back to me. Yes we can Africa
.
And go on to the
bar or nationalism to July. I'm going
to do but I don't want
to do the work drunk ground they're going
. To be
fun and it comes time for a week on a
lot that week again.
We're going to tell me. To me
if not your reaction when you found out.
Who my disability had to be a little bit and then I didn't really have a
very action very much you have.
I knew something was wrong from
being what it is was doing was wrong.
And if she could have been
wrong with me all my life because I'm a little on methadone was one glasses
of wine all my life I was never
coordinated couldn't I could run for oh
no no no good.
And there are deficits they're trying to
overcome it. He knows where to work.
But the reason I found out was because I was an emergency medical
technician in New Jersey and good region
squad and I. Had
too many times to enmeshed in this pain.
Yes it is minging when we started equating
that this is a pain in the ass disease.
But then again you can't just take
this one.
It's not worth it
but it's hardly ever think after which character
which is one
person gets sick and needs to try to prevent it asking around the
second or third or fourth.
There are four and out
. You put the person in the chair and yet there are handles fun to
see the handles on the legs and if you handle nights
you have walked upwards.
Because if I was going backwards and snares organized to go
. So slow so that
said were basically no moving.
This morning.
I dropped a person I was responding to a person
who suffers and that isn't a structure
dropped after heavy and
my has been wrong position. But it
looks bad because it dropped to the counseling. And
. Third time and we're taking a person
from bottom to catch and get get out from
behind the cat or be
bored. Looked it up and move with it
and lost it.
Usman growth and fell and
.
There were five months after sounds OK me
on but I can't and dinners and he took me aside
after a call and said look it's probably nothing but you should go to
a doctor and get this checked out. The doctor said
nothing but I can't tell what it is so you
get that he said No no nothing. But I
really can't do anything more I see I
said today and then they came back through that and
said Well it's definitely something
sclerosis but I can't tell you what it is so
you see this super specialized knowledge and it's New York.
Name Paul Green so I did and who lived
bothers assistant asked me and took him a couple
hours but he asked me and I have a very
the rarest form of taxi or.
Twenty versions of the text. And I don't have any of
.
Them and it's incurable it's just terrible for
me because they don't know what it is yet.
Then it's a tech Yeah but
those are the singers who may not be familiar with it.
Back to square one.
OK ed text is it demented to think.
Yes yes you can get any
disease into a
G.'s back of my brain then my
brain can't go is getting smaller every day
because it just keeps going off. And it's a
pretty important part of your brain control for us reaches twice
on the way. Do. You control swallowing
a very important part of your brain and all your
brains are here for you but this is the part
I think in mind it's a work right
. GROSS If
I notice who is just laying
on Long Island Duquesne you know in due form
matters and a lead to a walker now I want back to fly
around and trying to get
me to use a word terror and fighting. What do
they know it's probably shit.
I'm sure we'll make that decision.
Yeah it's rigged. You already have a chair. And
courage is that you see over there on the
wall are something I designed
called them by a bar and states that it's a cross between a right wing
sick and parents home run by
to make for not assembly committees
and even if they
. Were tipped off it
has to stand with a lot of Zite and sick. See he
needs an ice smashed case
and they are well known will follow his sheep
. I should want to.
So you know you told us you don't know a little bit about
your reaction to finding out about this but
you know.
How was it growing up and OK
Ben Spratt in New Jersey.
Oh I wasn't in the drawl of guilt
for three years I have right now
for two years.
TRACHTENBERG here.
So I don't know what I could write my own but I had no
idea and was wrong. I know these
things. Zucker tell bench I
think that I didn't get out of
game play of it because those
unearthed and wrote poetry is
kids you know they were born around us after all and
no I don't play evil described
. As an
example I don't think save minutes is lost to me since nineteen
ninety one. Let me
thank you both so I don't think they have.
The world and they
.
Can't play. Yeah. You know us Captain arrests and
pain because he couldn't rest of the bird out.
Right that's rather And how
do you know we have a big family. You know I one brother that work
and he's a great guy to me. He lives in
D.C. his wife and daughters is very
different in the snow or maybe it is
and just suppresses it. But he works with for of
his good job his wife to the doctor is.
For a filename.
And then he drives and I
don't build a new law
.
Or rather I say.
How was it or how was it
growing up in New Jersey you know you mentioned you you're going to
Cambridge What brought your family to Jaycee.
Well my father was born my father was a
nurse. Yes well I was born in Cambridge
trying to let you know I know
.
And down he went there to see a hairbrush Rocker's
universe is a lot faster. They were scared for their
life the rest of his life. And thirty seven years I think
he died sixty.
OK
Thank you.
So that's why I went to go you know
. We lived in a very old farmhouse and
could see you
know still could come on Sundays and find this to a
certain ceiling of the room holding that blasts
and no no I don't find that day.
But yeah.
So it was your family pretty supportive group.
Yeah various word of me.
Oh no my brother now. But it was very very supportive
of me.
They were you know you can't trust them to say oh
they didn't it.
So working hard and
back and seeing him making the game but having him do what they
can get to
you. Know very
. Well for soon and so I know
well how you know in tilting it are nationalists
OK left. Joey you know knows the brevity.
And so other than rock climbing leg would have been something
that you've enjoyed doing the writing life that we do for fun.
Well.
Like I said I was a camper for a long
night school we used to go to school year round. Bove would never
woke us live spring session and the swing
set and we'd have projects that we put in jail printed
art for all freshman and trial project you
had to he had to
make an effort in jail for a weak point or to grab
him but this isn't school net
right deal with meter so we had overnight
and write that for three years for
a fourth year. And
then after graduate came back as an adult for ten years
can work times so I
.
Just thought I would give out the name.
And artists are active cyclist
and me to contain which is more to take a club
and we were going to forensic it is it
was a bike.
There.
Are from the old world a guy
.
Who needs for sure you know kind of like air right.
Yeah yeah sure. OK OK you're wrong and
so are the go home there.
You imagine generally and then there's a lot of people who want
.
To tell me about some influences in your life or
people that you don't want day
Myra cloners
. CASM
Jorgensen and in
Croatia for Congress to do things that I just
couldn't do it would suit Boulder
. When you cut short her rights for roots with
ropes
Sasha is just you know or a bad ass.
Oh my are similar in the Shah she was
twelve or thirteen. Glad she's would imagine I could ever bear
. And it's just like him. So I know
are there. In this in his book
Brooklyn Yeah. Time to
Crestor book and here to
get the previous walks to Walt I think tap
writers two hundred sixth Street but it's a
lot of fun. He found a community and definitely
a walk in there. Most
children is me but I know they're out there
and I asked
one out of Congress rather than out
near times. So part of us
and they had a kind of
handle. To everyone could redo it a CD.
And when I was with Alvin the man and the hands
away from me on board
. And I don't know about
his blog in fact I'm in there right now.
So yeah it's a good thing.
Could community they support you they get this
rotten buggers who could see
a bugger to fund a fund of mining
bloat. Oh good to be here
for our work.
And John lefty sort of blew my
cage which is great.
And we'll become friends over here
.
What is your process to what is your problem. Process
I do have a rock
but I had an appointee have to have a list
yet but this is driven by head to
head.
That's rich. I
warned them that they
want revolve around them. But there are various critics we are
all forced you know. And. So
I took up the roots a little bit eating lunch strategy
John.
Well it is
said to now I can't go on
.
The use you use and you can prove you are
going to be fired. Why
.
Is this
that this is such
.
A. C.
work.
Do you
.
Want. To try
to swerve current.
But Burton worker's book
is
.
Mind over matter and pain taxi and ask.
Yes to evade my cage match. Column and asked how it would be
where one person who's come to Iraq.
And talk to you you were a half head to head
.
I say I'm going to read I
Mean read a claim is the most important thing to
me Ed and Elaine claim we are and we ask and this exact
one and pay attention and stop looking at my hands and really you know
down to him to reach an understanding.
Supposed to look at us. What else am I supposed to
do. Yeah well.
So anyone can check. Why take it
so well.
What changed will change for you or for others
. You know when you started your journey you know
greasing your disability and
. You know really
just living living with that.
Well I was too gracefully. Oh
yeah
.
Oh God.
I have no choice but to leave because
it's a part of me it's a big part of me it's not all thing
that is not disabled.
Remember. Oh but a friend of mine named dresses
that is one of the good skier. And he
says I don't think of myself but it's a long
brown nose
.
I don't think of myself as disabled and I don't think of myself as disabled
that.
I mean yes I know I am, but I
.
Didn't mean doesn't mean, oh I enjoy doing things that people don't think
will do which includes rock climbing, includes
walking around the snow. Falling on the bus
which I did, which I did quite often, I did it last night
. Actually
um
The bus driver?, Oh my God can I help you off the bus, no
Oh OK I got it?, but I didn't fall I hit the wall
So yes, but I just love doing things that people don't think I
think I can do. And you've really succeeded
.
They say Oh I'm not done yet. Hopefully
What's on the pipeline. Well there is a next world
t?. Paris in 2016 and I have to get a
medal at the paraclimbing championships and ah try
? sixteen.
And that's one thing I have to nail
and I'm just gonna keep being a
bad ass. Which is something I say
say?
I can't stop and I don't want to give
up biking so I'm going do a ride down into Staten Island
summer, to where, Staten Island I want to go all the way down
hit bottom ten percent
?. what the beaches are like down there. So I don't know.
And I swear that it's about an 80 ride, round trip
I've got this one friend interested, I have to actually plan it
in the Staten Island trip.
Yeah actually but
?.
Be done. It can't, I'm sure it has been done ?
also I want to get, I don't know what
is ?
re up with them, so I'm continuing to follow new pathways
to sponsorship, see if maybe ?
? to be interested in me.
Like our paraclimbers maybe that's
we ah put the industry in a good light
?
So sometimes I feel like capitalising that way too much
but if they're willing to give me the money I'm willing to do the work
and for our listeners who might not be familiar with paraclimbing or
climbing
what are the, what's the distinction
Well paraclimbing is a disabled climb, uh a lot of my
friends are missing limbs.
One of my friends who won the gold at the world, she had a
caught in a building in the earthquake in Haiti to the knee
another one of my friends that won the gold
was born without a hand.
But really did climbing and they were climbing for
longer then I have been. Um I
another friend is, lots of friends
like Ron is missing pretty much
his entire left leg and he's, he can be doing the ABS
procomp with the able bodied athletes, he didn't go
very hard but he competed.
? picture of him doing the bat hang
After a while
Bat hanging? upside down hanging by the tips of his feet. One
them is an artificial prosthetic, which I
tearing it off.
But he didn't
um. It's a very impressive community. Yeah we
all know each other pretty well.
There aren't that many disabled paraclimbers, so we're a
pretty small community and as they're good, know each other
And so you you have this supportive
community you're you're um hoping to plan this trip to Staten
Island so New York is, New York is your stomping
ground,  tell
New York is home base. Tell me what it's like to be in New
York or tell me about that identity
I really don't have a New York ? I've given the subway
to book ? hands a week.
Um in the summer I ride my bike a lot around New York
also I've done New Jersey riding over the George Washington bridge
near New Jersey so I've done that then, that's our
say I've ridden around there.
New York is just a place to a hang a hat, it's where I live.
I love it because it has a subway ? bus
good um if I went to
car and since I don't know how to drive ?
too difficult. I can get a car but
I do want to try to get
again if I don't get a car which is not
something in New York at least I can rent one if I need to go somewhere
biking distance.
And and you mention that
You you've got your eye on that Paris prize right.
Yes definitely, very definitely
?
last year, um
I really want to get to fountain blue
outside of Paris, I don't know how far outside of Paris but
in Spain we rented a car so we spent time
? so I begged to see if maybe we can take a week
have some climbing areas maybe dry run ? a little bit
that'd be fun, and I also want to ? climb so that I can
become better at this stuff.
You wanna learn how to, ? climb
? climbing space, we call it being at the sharp end of the rope
tightened to the rope, you're at the very end of it
think it's if your ? broke ? you have rope ? harness up into the
? and down into a ? So you can fall with impunity
you don't lose anything. If you're leaning you can fall but you can
fall upto about to twenty feet, depending on where you
are. And it's a skill it's not easy to learn, I learned the
hard way is that it ? fell and
I almost hit the ground.
the Go-pro on my head did hit the ground
and it fell off. I was upside down
but I was okay ?
One bad
I was unhurt
Even though my friend Marie who's rope I was using kinda
laughed at me ? to rope.
Did you replace it, no she replaced it, I didn't
No! Ropes are expensive and one
fall wouldn't have done it. ? a lot that week
so. This was in Spain in ?
ropes at their practice gym
so we used her rope for that, so a lot of people fall
.
It wasn't just me so I wouldn't have replaced it, I may replace
?
And she knows that, that's why she was joking around. You have a
great sense of humor you, thank you, you
um
Well if you can't laugh about what makes you ill what can you do
I don't want to cry about it. I've seen people who cried about their illness
and it's just not any fun
and people who don't ? apartments
What do you want to tell people like that, or what's your
message, my message is well
.
The message of the climbing group is anyone can climb
um
where as my favourite quote is um
? sometimes courage is ? at the end of the day
they think we'll try again tomorrow, so I guess ?
? to suceed try and try again ?
like that I guess that's my message. And try try
again has worked for me.
How did you... How did you
did you cope. You know when you
some of your first failures, some of your first challenge, some of your first challenges, Well
for the first two years that I had
this... That I knew I had this disease
um
I, I was awful.
?
I didn't know how to react. I was apologising to people for things that I
couldn't control. You know sending drunken telephone
thing. No I'm not joking or getting very defensive about it.
after a while I just sat there ? it's not worth it.
You can only be angry for so long until you just get tired of it
.
What made you change your perspective.
I don't know, I think it's just the way I am, it helps a lot going on in my life
good things going on and I had good friends. I was in New Jersey at the time
Wasn't ?.
um I was ? 1997 so
Long time. Ago um
But for the first two years I was still hiking, I was still
volunteering with the same ?
just trying to live my life and you know living my life seemed like a pretty good deal
for me, so that was it. And you've been
doing it since, I have been and it's a pretty good deal for me
.
What do you want to tell, what do you want to tell
people, people who don't, who haven't
experienced what you have, just try it, just try it
it's worth it, it
feels very good, even if you don't suceed it feels good and
also exercise will help your disease.
I had a friend once
who had heard from her doctor that she should not exercise with her ?
cause it would be bad for her and I didn't agree with it
? I think she's dead. I haven't talked to her in years.
But she was, she just did nothing. She didn't
got things from her and people get things from me too sometimes. Like the
water, thank you.
But um
um.
I do that for me because I want to. They did that for her, well they wanted to
?
I think if you just try, you'll surprise
yourself. And at present
yourself and it's surprising that it like I've said it before feels very good
I don't know that's about all I can say
getting this right
Every ?, Yeah yeah thank you for sharing that
.
Is there something else you want to tell, you know tell
listeners or tell people in the disability community or
what are, what are some last words you want to share
It's a final thought
um
Toughest question, it is a tough question.
?
.
I hate to say it but I really don't have anything else
to say, I've pretty much said what I wanted to say.
I, well I do,
I want to add that
Is there anything else you wanted to ask me, I feel l'll probably have
some questions ?
? after that, I think I think I might actually
I've been meaning to head over to Brooklyn boulders
because the I actually visited the won
they opened in Chicago, oh you did. I've wanted, how is that gym, I've wanted to
visit there for a long time, it was, that was my
first climbing experience, they also have one they've got
? Well it just
was ? big, yeah I don't think it they were that high in
Chicago, no they're 50 feet I think. 26 foot
was really ? size small there and what I liked is
in Georgia last year for the nationals
60-80 foot walls, they were huge
and they were just so much fun, I would say
I that it was so much fun when I went there and I took my eighteen year
old brother who's on the autism spectrum
mmm, and ah
He, he was so happy and so excited
to be there and listening to you.
I've found that cause we do outreach programs ?
like we climb with the group
Pediatrics two times a year I think and it's
great fun. Watch 2 and 3 year olds getting up the wall and they're having a great time
we're having a great time
and um
that's why I do what I do, I remeber one of my friends Doug
put a poster for his work.
Where he was ? this little kid out the wall and then just ?
everything is all right with my world and that's the way you feel
the world. It's empowering.
So where does your brother live, He lives in Chicago, ah because I was going
to say on Thursday's
at 6 o'clock and ah we'd be happy to climb with him
you know what, I I'm thinking about bringing him to New York this summer so I think
that'd be great, we'd be happy to climb with him.
Thank you, you just need to register on our website adaptive
climbing.org, active climbing, no adaptive, adaptive climbing
.org
What to expect
Okay, and cost is 11 dollars
with all the equipment rental and everything
No I just. Just listening to you talk
about how exciting and
how motivated you are to do, to climb and um
improve your technique is, it makes me feel like
I need to stop miking, okay
thank you, you're welcome, thank you um
Well Adam, ah thank you so much for
taking your time to share your story, your passion
about you know all these facets of your life um
This concludes our interview
Ok, uh painless.
But um again my, my name is um Monica Diaz and
I just had a conversation with Adam Pine for a, Payne
Payne, I'm so sorry, that's alright, and I just had a conversation with Adam Payne
for Visible Lives, an Oral History Project at the New York Public
Library. Thank you so much Adam, you're welcome.